- Bladesmiths, this
I'm going to be taking
each of your dirks
and testing them by
hammering them six times
each into this oil can.
Remember, this test is all
about what happens to the dirks.
Phil, you're up first.
You ready?
- Yes, sir.
[music playing]
I'm feeling nervous because
when I see the oil drum
for the first time,
I'm thinking, well,
that could break at that point.
[music playing]
[thudding]
No respect for that barrel.
[laughs] That poor barrel.
[music playing]
Well, Phil.
It held up pretty well.
A little bit of rolling
at the edge here.
Minor, but still there.
In all, the dirk
held up very well.
Good job, man.
Doran, you're up next.
You ready?
Kill that thing.
[thudding]
[music playing]
Die.
Well, Doran, you
still have a dirk.
It's not razor sharp anymore.
Down here, there's
just a little rolling.
But the handle is
relatively small for a dirk,
but comfortable.
Overall, very well done.
Thank you, sir.
Jonathan, you're up.
Ready.
I'm a little worried because
you can crack the blade,
you can dull the blade.
You can drive the blade
clean out of the handle.
Anything can go wrong.
[thudding]
[music playing]
Well, Jonathan, in
all, it held up well.
But at the handle, it's a
little sharp towards the front.
It's not quite as comfortable
to grip as some of the others.
But I like your choice of wood.
In total, it's still
a fighting knife.
Well done.
All right, gentlemen.
Next up, the sharpness test.
Now, unlike the strength
test, this is all about what
your knives do to these apples.
A sharp edge should
give me a good clean cut
straight through those apples.
A dull edge, well, we
could see the apples crack,
or you could see the skin torn.
Phil, you're up first.
You ready?
- Yes, sir.
[music playing]
- Good job.
- Yeah.
All right, Phil,
right off the bat,
I love the profile
of your knife.
That classic shape.
It cut cleanly
through these apples.
But right at the edge, you can
see these little flaps of skin.
There's one section on this
knife where it took that roll.
Definitely a sharp knife though.
A good cutter.
Nicely done.
- Thank you, sir.
- Doran, you're up.
You ready?
I am nervous.
I might spent too much time
on my handle and not enough
time on my blade.
[music playing]
You blade does have
an edge and it will cut.
But that one inch by 3/8
of an inch is a wedge.
OK.
This first apple, it's
got a cut to about here.
And then the rest of
this is actually broken.
For a slicing blade, it just--
it's fighting.
All right, Jonathan.
You're up.
Let's do it.
My blade suffered the worst
damage in the barrel stab.
It has the least finished
handle on the floor.
Anything could send
me home at this point.
[music playing]
Nice.
First off, you've got a
big convex edge to this,
which cut really nicely.
But there are a
couple of small rolls.
And your handle, though
shaped nicely this way,
is very lean here.
But it's definitely a cutter.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
[music playing]
Bladesmiths, the judges'
deliberation is complete
and they've made
their final decision.
The bladesmith
leaving the forge is--
[music playing]
--Doran.
Your blade did not make the cut.
David Baker's going
to tell you why.
Doran, you made a
solid knife there.
And I really appreciate
the fact that you listened
and re-profiled that tip.
But in the slice test
and the sharpness test,
your blade with that wedge
profile, just didn't cut.
That's why we're letting you go.
Doran, please
surrender your weapon.
[music playing]
I'm not upset that I lost
or I didn't get to where I
need to be in this competition.
These are tears of joy.
This has happened.
I just lived out a dream.
And for somebody who's living
in a little town like I do,
this is worth more than gold.
[music playing]